russia has invaded ukraine and the
situation is moving fast
here are the key areas to keep an eye on
crimea sits at the south of ukraine on
the black sea
in 2014 it was annexed by russia that
means it was forcibly seized
[Music]
it gave putin expanded access to the
black sea a key trade and transportation
link and somewhere he already has a big
military presence and it provides easy
access to ukraine south
also along ukraine's south coast odessa
and mario polk they're significant as
they're home to some of ukraine's naval
bases
on ukraine's east in what's known as the
donbass two of the nation's oblasts or
regions are particularly important
around three and a half million people
live in donetsk and luhans the majority
of whom speak russian
russian-backed separatists seized parts
of those two areas in 2014 calling them
people's republics they claim to control
both but actually control about a third
they held a vote to declare independence
and even elected self-proclaimed
presidents the rest of the world doesn't
recognize him but on the 21st of
february vladimir putin did
also in the east is ukraine's second
most popular city kharkiv it's easy
access for russia and not long after
putin announced his invasion shelling
was heard here
vladimir putin and belarusian leader
alexander lokashenko are close allies as
well as bordering russia belarus shares
a key border with ukraine
throughout february russia has been
conducting joint military drills with
belarus making a play for kiev from the
north involves going past chernobyl the
site of the 1986 nuclear disaster this
could have huge ramifications experts
say artillery and mortars in the belarus
ukraine border area could disturb
radioactive debris in the soil there are
reports russian forces are in the area
ukraine's president called the move a
declaration of war against the whole of
europe
ukraine plays a key role delivering
russian gas to europe and russia is the
main supplier of natural gas to the eu
as you can see there are a lot of
pipelines carrying russian gas through
ukraine to europe nordstrom 2 a pipeline
from russia to europe via the baltic sea
would have avoided ukraine completely
however as part of sanctions against
russia it's been scrapped
what is clear is that the west strategy
of threatening sanctions to deter an
invasion does not seem to be working
[Music]
you